[Musique]
bienvenue à tous dans cette émission
spéciale consacrée à la semaine de la
presse qui vous le savez se tient dans
les collèges dans les lycées dans les
écoles aussi semaine de la presse qui
permet d'avoir des contacts entre eux
certains journalistes d'ailleurs thémis
318 est assez présente a été assez
présent cependant cette semaine et puis
aussi commander contact avec des élèves
qu'est ce que c'est pour eux la
formation comment ils s'informent par
quel biais par quelle voie et on va
parler de tout ça pendant cette édition
avec mes invités maryse bruce taille
bonjour bonjour vous êtes professeur
d'histoire à mantes-la-jolie au lycée
saint-exupéry et vous êtes un des bandes
du clemi or on expliquera ce qu'est le
clemi tout à l'heure le rosier bonjour
bonjour vous êtes professeur de lettres
en collège pablo picasso de montesson
oui des collèges avec collègue dan
harris broustaricq collègues et bien sûr
bien sûr vous êtes tous les deux membres
du clergé des responsables du clemi on
va en parler naturellement
et puis alors quelques élèves chloé ce
nouveau bonjour vous êtes élève de
terminale au lycée de montesson bonjour
marc thiberville
vous êtes également élève de terminale
bonjour bonjour mon père kolbe vous êtes
élève de terminale à mentalement
tragédie maintenant la web radio du
lycée c'est ça et djibril gamme de thés
bonjour vous êtes élève de seconde alors
vous êtes le plus jeune d'entre nous
donc ne soyez pas impressionné web ça va
être très sympa vous nous raconter
pourquoi pourquoi ça vous intéresse
quand même la formation est ce que ça
fait partie justement à l'information et
la formation et à pas tous les mêmes
racines et c'est important
peut-être un mot pour commencer de cette
semaine de la presse qui a lieu à
risbourg stein en quoi c'est important
et en quoi elle consiste au fond cette
semaine cette semaine de la presse c'est
un c'est un temps fort en fait quand on
fait de l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information donc c'est une occasion
qui est donnée par me parmi d'autres de
faire de l'éducation aux médias et à la
formation et pour nous elle est
importante parce que ça nous permet de
promouvoir des activités qui permettent
aux élèves de mieux s'informer ou en
tout cas de réfléchir à la patience il
s'informe et à la façon dont les
informations gmt a eu il ya exercé leur
esprit critique à l'égard de septembre à
mai lionel roux style vif avant même
question n'est pas évident comme amis
mais ça mais bon même question oui sur
l'importance au fond de ce rapport qui
est pourquoi vous vous renseignez vous
êtes heureux
professeur de lettres maryse
broussailles professeur d'histoire
géographie
qu'est ce qui vous a incité à choisir la
formation m consacrés au four a consisté
en dehors de deux de vos autres courts à
l'information et à vider des élèves
en fait c'est pas vraiment en dehors de
mes cours d'abord cessé au programme
c'est à dire que ni son média la
formation est au sénat ces matières en
plus si ce n'est que ce sont toutes les
autres enfin cette matière qui est qui
peut être fait dans toutes les autres
matières bien sûr les professeurs
documentalistes sont les les
professionnels qui sont privilégiés pour
enseigner ce de cette matière là mais
nous sommes aussi invité et inciter
d'ailleurs dans les autres disciplines à
travailler l'éducation et à la formation
des moyens vraiment quelque chose
d'institutionnels ça fait aussi partie
de du socle du socle commun de
compétences de connaissances cette
culture attendu en fin de cycle et donc
ça ça fait partie dans les textes des
des compétences à travailler mais après
c'est vrai que
à titre personnel j'y trouve un intérêt
parce que l'éducation médias
l'information professeur de lettres
permet à la fois aux élèves de
développer de leurs compétences de
lecteurs des supports divers comme
disait ma collègue aussi de développer
leur esprit critique et puis de
également c'est un bouquin c'est
également un merveilleux outil de
publication d'expression des élèves est
là aussi en tant qu on sorte de lettre
avoir un moyen d un même une
multiplicité de moyens de s'exprimer
c'est si une occasion de diversifier les
modes d'expression chez les élèves à
l'oral comme à l'écrit
chloé marveaux et anna alors je prends
blog mais ça qui va répondre disais tout
à l'heure et lève toutes trois en
terminale
ça fait quelques années que vous formez
à l'information
chloé alana par exemple alors fort mais
je sais pas mais ça fait quelques années
que j'essaie de suivre les informations
et c'est cette année que je travaille
sur la web radio
donc je pense qu'elle avait battue
organisée par madame grosse taille et
c'est vrai que ça m'a apporté un regard
plus formateur sur l'information je
recommanderais à créer et aussi du coup
comment la recevoir par saison est ce
que ça a changé pour vous la façon dont
vous informez votre rapport à la
formation ou est ce que je sais pas
quels sont les modes privilégiée
d'information qui sont les vôtres
je pense que la formation il a vraiment
changé cette année surtout parce que
j'ai fait une préparation pour les
écoles supérieures et riku suivre tout
le temps les informations et de les
traiter par exemple en dossier
d'articles faire une synthèse etc
et donc j'ai l'habitude de maintenant ne
plus lire par exemple des articles je
travaille beaucoup avec la presse mais
potentiellement sur mon téléphone chaque
jour j'essaie de lire un peu la presse
ou mondiaux ces lots est le même
même même analyse que thomas oui alors
moi c'était un troisième jeu j'étais
dans la classe
médias chaque fois que je joue j'essaie
toujours de recul par rapport à ce que
je lis et toujours vérifier mes enfants
bâtiment avant de croire directement est
ce que je vois où ce que je suis et
est-ce que je me posais la question à
margaux naturellement aussi mais est-ce
que ça entraîne mais ce qui est des
informations comme ça qui entraîne des
discussions entre autres les élèves on
n'est pas d'accord il ya quelqu'un qui
me dit mais non tu dis n'importe quoi
c'est pas comme ça que ça s'est passé
bah oui oui pas encore
bah du coup ça fait longtemps que j'ai
fait la classe mais bon quand je débats
avec les amis forcément des riches et
leurs sources parce que parfois ce qui s
annonce
c'est juste des choses qu'ils ont vu sur
le réseau et qui sont pas du tout
fondées
c'est vrai que c'est souvent internet
les réseaux sociaux qui sont les
principales sources d'information
margot vous aussi vous aimez vous
aujourd'hui peut-être avoir des sources
d'information plus diversifiée que vous
donnerez fait peut-être si vous n'avez
pas suivi ce genre de formation oui bah
grâce à la classe médias belges aient pu
élargir mes sources je regarde les
articles sur internet j'ai aussi
installé twitter qui est un bon réseau
pour s'informer même s'il faut bien
vérifier ses sources et du coup j'ai
beaucoup diversifiés mon rapport aux
informations
quels sont les quels sont les sujets qui
vous passionne le plus en ce moment je
dirais la santé du coût sanitaire ça
prend quand même une grande place du
coup j'essaye de me renseigner
surtout que je veux suivre des études de
santé plus tard donc c'est un peu lié
d'accord vivre il alors je me disais
vous êtes tous encore en seconde
qu'est ce qui vous intéresse ou dans
donc comme ça que dans la masse
d'informations qui peut arriver est ce
que d'abord excuse que voilà ce que vous
avez l'impression d'être un peu noyé
dans toute désinformation ou alors vous
vous débrouillez plutôt bien dans ce que
jo ce qui nous intéresse
j'irai mais parfois comme indien il ya
trop d'informations ce qui est humain je
ne sais pas vraiment où donner de la
tête
c'est quoi votre matière presse qu'est
ce que vous regardez vous plutôt j'ai
passé ça peut être la culture ça peut
être l'économie un peu de la politique
ça peut être le sport ça peut être la
sauter ça va être l'environnement
moi c'est plus le sport le score et
québécois dans le sport c'est à dire
quelles qu'elles soient bons du tr pour
un très généralement qu'elles font
d'accord vous souhaitez le psg dans
cette série c'est bien mais là aussi
c'est vrai que parfois voilà on a des
informations peu contradictoire on sait
pas il ya beaucoup de choses sérieuses
dans le football sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment
vous vous vous essayez de vous informer
comment ces internet d'abord c'est le
réseau soins lourds céder celle du
sélectives surtout internet
will à la télévision de sa division
générale alors on va on va repartir avec
ma taille et de naviguer sur sur ces
classes alors le clemi déjà défini des
nous définissent est ce que c est
pourquoi ça a été créée et qu'elle et
qui est sûre les met des buts c'est
alors le clemi donc ça signifie sans nom
de liaison à l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information
c'est une organisation qui a plus de 30
ans on a fêté ses 30 ans 19 de mémoire
et en fait c'est une organisation qui a
pour but de promouvoir l'éducation aux
médias et à l'information en faisant le
lien donc le mot liaison entre les
professionnels des médias donc
journalisme ou les métiers des médias
comme le vôtre et les élèves depuis
l'école primaire et maternelle pour les
plus jeunes jusque jusqu'au au lycée et
donc c'est une institution en fait qui a
mis en place progressivement des grands
temps forts donc là on parle de la
semaine de la presse et des médias il ya
aussi des concours du milieu scolaire
par exemple djibril avec sa classe ont
participé au concours de photoreportage
on a des concours de médias de type web
radios etc
donc voila tu as un organisme qui
cherche à promouvoir et à valoriser et à
inciter à faire de l'éducation aux
médias et à l'information le hellwig et
sur ceux sur ce que les mille et
l'importance que pourquoi pourquoi cette
aujourd'hui à votre avis essentiel sinon
c'est pourquoi c'est essentiel de
promouvoir cette éducation
cette éducation wydad oui qu'est-ce que
ça correspond à une demande d'aidé des
élèves des parents ou est ce que c'est
une nécessité après tout de service
public qua non mais c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant de savoir ça fait plus de
trente ans que le pied magique
donc il ya une éducation médias qui se
fait le clemi accompagne depuis 30 plus
de trente ans après c'est vrai que on
voit qu'il y a enfin moi je trouvais
c'est ça ça ça n'engage que moi mais qui
a de plus en plus une urgence à éduquer
aux médias et à la formation
comme l'a très bien dit je trouve des
briques justement le fait qu' on est on
est tous les jeunes les moins jeunes de
noyer dans les informations
il est vraiment essentiel d'apprendre à
lire les informations faire le tri à
faire nuance t chaque source qu'on peut
avoir à les distinguer à faire la part
des choses enfin c'est vraiment il ya un
an un afflux d'informations margot par
des twitters appareils 1 sur twitter
c'est c'est vraiment énorme le flux
d'informations sur les réseaux sociaux
est énorme et donc ben faut arriver à se
dépatouiller dans tout cela et pour cela
effectivement la formation des élèves
est importante
et le clemi est là pour assurer aussi la
formation des enseignants
parce qu'on a un monde qui évoluent
extrêmement vite des médias
d'information ou pas d'information mais
qui deviennent des médias d'information
je parle des réseaux sociaux surtout qui
évolue aussi extrêmement vite et donc
bah c'est vrai qu'on doit s'adapter à
cette évolution là et ils évoluent plus
vite que paris les évoluent extrêmement
vite donc faut arriver à suivre
pas évident donc vivement le premi le
clemi est là pour est aussi là pour
former cette partie de ses missions
former accompagner les enseignants dans
leur accompagnement des élèves et les
familles aussi d'alain le clemi aussi sa
famille aussi parce que c'est un parti
il ya aussi peut-être une demande des
familles de deux cette formation est
content d une enseigne dans ces domaines
est ce que il faut à la fois savoir une
idée des élèves parce que c'est le
boulot des profs mais il faut savoir
aussi être à l écoute
non tout à fait oui tout à fait ouais
tout à fait en fait ce qui se fait
surtout l'important est ce n'est pas
évident pour nous les professeurs c'est
qu'en un tour des élèves d'à peu près du
même âge en face de nous mais nous on
est heureusement on prend de l'âge et
les façons de s'informer ou les façons
dont les informations arrivent aux
élèves se modifie et comme le dit du
ring en fait ces graisses des médias qui
sont encore regardé un peu par les
élèves qui sont la télévision mais je
crois que entre twitter et puis la
presse en ligne ont cédé medec sont peu
présents la presse en ligne c'est une
presse écrite mais ce sont des mines etc
sont un peu nouveau et donc il faut
aussi que nous on sache écouter les
élèves sur la façon dont ils s'informent
ou en tout cas sur la façon dont les
informations peuvent venir à eux il faut
aussi qu'on les écoute sur leur
questionnement parce que tout à l'heure
djibril disait trop d'infos je suis un
peu perdu c'est aussi un nom voilà de
les aider à faire le tri je crois que
c'est cauet qui parlait des sources
d'information avec avec ses camarades
c'est super intéressant et c'est
vraiment crucial que d'expliquer aux
élèves ce que c'est qu'une source et que
google n'est pas une source nachat n'est
pas une source
c'est un travail chez ikea très très
important est toujours très intéressant
donc oui il faut être à l'écouté des
élèves
il faut accepter de rendre ce qu'ils
vont nous proposer aussi et puis il faut
malheureusement se former est très
régulièrement pour ne pas être dépassé
non plus l'enseignant c'est vrai que je
rejoins beaucoup
collègues parce que là dessus sur le
lait coûte à avoir par rapport à leurs
pratiques
c'est pas moi même une première étape
dans la manière d'aborder l'information
avec eux c'est à dire comment vous vous
informer dites moi comment est ce que
vous voyez sur les réseaux sociaux quels
sont les réseaux vous utilisez ou alors
qu'est ce que vous regardez la
télévision qu'est ce que vous écoutez
comme radio bien sûr les pratiques aussi
sont diversifiées aux accents d'une même
classe c'est on va pas tout peut pas non
plus rentrer dans la caricature
l'adolescent d'aujourd'hui sans fard ni
comme ça dont il ya plusieurs pratiques
informationnel chez les jeunes mais
c'est vrai que c'est une première étape
pour moi qui semble essentiel qui est de
s'intéresser en fait à leur manière de
s'informer alors une manière de
communiquer aussi puisque scellier c'est
intimement liés et être à l'écouté
effectivement adaptés sont adaptés
éventuellement sont soit son discours
soissons son cours à à ce qu'on
identifie comme étant des besoins je
sais mais il ya des demandes qui sont
parfois formulés ou pas tout à fait
formule est d'ailleurs c'est là qu'il
faut être
il faut vraiment aller coûte passer ça
ça fait mal et j'ai regardé un peu vous
devez envoyer le lien d'une web radio
alors c'est la web radio de montesson le
lien je vous avais envoyé c'est le site
internet de la classe médias de
montesson de moncton qui est un
dispositif qui est liste existe depuis
2014 donc alors dans laquelle il dit
versailles on a des classes médias qui
sont qui ont un label mass médias un
label du cmit versailles et la dame de
versailles label institutionnel la
montée sont on a on a effectivement de
classe médias qui meurent qui n'est pas
labellisé par l'académie parce que l'on
n'est pas forcément dans ce dispositif
mais en tout cas c'est une classe médias
qu'on a depuis 2014 et on a pour
habitude de toujours publié sur ce blog
ils ont aussi leur compte twitter un
compte instagram avec des publications
effectivement sur les sur ses différents
comptes et sur le blog effectivement il
ya de la webradio et aussi dans les bois
tv vraiment des publications de super
utilisant des deals des supports très
divers alors il ya plusieurs sujets on
va pouvoir revenir sur lequel les élèves
atterries je vais vous en parlait
justement avec anna avec
louez votre parcours et avec dibril j'ai
vu par exemple il y avait toute une
émission qu'elle était faite sur le
harcèlement à l'école
je voudrais vous demander chloé hannah
margot dibril est ce que justement cette
éducation aux médias ça peut vous
permettre grâce à l'actualité de parler
de problèmes qui peuvent concerner les
élèves et dont il ne parlerait pas
autrement
je pense avoir seulement ce n'est pas
facile on en parle et c'est pas facile
d'en parler peut-être entre nm
messi a fait qui s'est déroulée quelque
part il vous a interpellé
c'est peut-être plus simple de le faire
qui veut répondre à ça je pense que
contre le fait de rendre publique une
libération de la parole s'engagera
d'autre part les webradios à laquelle
vous participez à mantes sait comment
elle fonctionne comment comment ça se
passe alors pendant ce temps j'ai
enregistré un papier
enfin j'ai pas manquer une interview
pourrait on dire des trottoirs
encourageant de tout tester
je trouve que c'est contre vraiment
choisir un sujet le rapport aux cours ou
encore faire un exposé et sait
transmettre une connaissance dans un
cadre non pas vraiment choisir un sujet
je me semble intéressant d'actualité et
de société etc et on parle aux autres et
ça c'est bon mais c'était sur quoi votre
le papier que vous avez fait c'était sur
la stérilisation forcée les etats unis
adacore histoire est un peu un peu
d'actualité maintenant parce qu'on a
très longtemps qu'il y avait peut-être
encore de la stérilisation forcée non
mais ça c'est formidable parce que voilà
une information qui n'a pas forcément
fait la une de tous les journaux mais
vous avez été la chercher ça vous
intéressez vous allez vous lui faisiez
vous avez vous lu heures enquêter si je
peux dire sur ce sujet ça parce qu'on en
attendait énormément pas vraiment
pourquoi interpellé qu'on puisse encore
faire ça aujourd'hui ça paraît assez
incroyable et du coup c'est ça qui
m'intéressait dans le partage et le
gleut et margot vous participez aussi à
des web radios des médias bon que moi
non plus est clos et non plus mais alors
vous quelques mois on a parlé des choses
d'information nous avait dit tout à
l'heure que j'ai essayé de multiplier
ses sources d'information qu'est-ce qui
est question d'aborder les domaines
margot par exemple question des domaines
vous qui de prédilection comme s'il nous
avait pas internet ou un journal sur
quoi vous précipiter au premier enfin
les faits d'actualité en général après
j'essaye de me renseigner un peu sur
tout ce qui se passe dans le monde
j'avais pas très sport ou ce genre de
choses ne seraient plus sur soi bas les
avancées technologiques scientifiques et
ses terrains voilà photo tv de rudy un
la santé pas du coup c'est un peu lié à
mon orientation alors ça c'est
intéressant parce que j'ai vu que dans
la web radio monter son évier reçu
thomas husson de macho c'est un
journaliste qui est un peu spécialiste
de du ou de la désinformation des
défaites news du complotisme chloé maru
margot pardon on a vu beaucoup
non non non non non toute la crise
sanitaire qui s'est déroulé avec ce
virus
on a vu beaucoup de désinformation il ya
même eu un film qui était donc été un
fil de complotisme nous vous avez à peu
regardé ces informations ensemble disons
tiens qu'est-ce qui est vrai qu est ce
qu ils peuvent re est ce qu'on peut le
savoir
c'est pas facile d'ailleurs oui bah je
me suis renseigné déjà parce que ma
tante peuvent envoyer toutes un lien
comme ça où il ya des gens qui pensaient
que le vaccin était fait pour inoculer
la 5g
dray
coup après oui il faut faire la part des
choses entre ce qui paraît complètement
surréaliste et ce qui serait possible
mais pour la plupart du temps il est
heureux du couple au enfin pour ma part
quand je les cherche se révèle être
complètement infondées mais est-ce
qu'avec vos camarades
vous pouvez avoir des discussions
là-dessus ou irakiens disent si si c'est
fait pour que nul à 5 g par qui sont
persuadés de sa pas forcément de cette
information la mémé qui est qui qui sont
qui sont sensibles à ces théories du
complot ben généralement parfois quand
ils voient par exemple des impressions
sur twitter ou ce genre de choses
j'ai des amis qui peuvent avoir tendance
à y croire directement mais après si
jamais on creuse un peu le sujet souvent
et justement cette formation ça vous a
permis de creuser à ne pas croire ce
qu'on dit au premier abord quoi tout à
fait parce qu'on a eu toute une
formation devait présenter justement les
informations chaque matin et parfois on
va présenter aussi des faits que news et
on se rend compte qu'il y en a
énormément en fait il ya même des sites
spécialisés dans l'effectif donc et vous
allez regarder par curiosité pour voir
jusqu'où ils vous oui c'est sûr le gora
fier ou ce genre de choses
oui c'est tellement tiré par les cheveux
que le graphisme nouvelle gare à fils
était vraiment de l'humour alors c'est
revendiquer comme étant de détournement
de l'information ce d'une manière
humoristique donc ils sont ils se
cachent pas ils n'essayent pas de faire
passer et l'aigle ici pour les lanternes
au mondial ça passe il faut pour le vrai
le ils sont déclarés de cet humoriste
plus tôt mais c'est drôle oui mais
justement ce qui est drôle c'est que
parfois il ya même des gens qui
reprennent les titres pour en faire
comme si c'était un vrai titre
d'information fait absolument vous avez
raison je me souviens qu'il y avait eu
comme ça et latines d'hugo raffy je
crois que c'était c'était ça se passait
à paris et c'était une dame avait été
arrêté parce qu'elle avait souri dans le
métro
et bien que l'information était repris
par des journaux sérieux
c'est pour ça que c'était vrai et ça
c'est maryse montaillé et et lionel
viguier c'est intéressant ça parce que
au fond comment reconnaître le vrai du
faux
cc c'est un vrai travail c'est pas et
c'est pas un travail qui toujours
évident on non c'est un travail qui est
très compliqué et est en fait plutôt que
de dire comment reconnaître le vrai du
faux
attendez plutôt sur quel degré de serait
fière que tu annonces comme information
et qu'est ce qu'il ya comme degré de
faux parce qu'on n'est jamais vraiment
manque totalement binaire bref on est
effectivement c'est pas facile à faire
travailler alors dans la calèche de
jerry par exemple on va travailler sur
des images des photographies et donc je
leur ai demandé si si si la légende qui
l'accompagnait alors sembler être juste
qu'ils ont un petit travail de fact
checking à faire à la maison pour
vérifier et je pense que pour que les
élèves puissent progressivement se
repérer en arriver au niveau de margaux
de chloé ou de la natation un terminal
il faut quand même faire des activités
assez régulière parce que c'est la
pratique régulière de sur l'esprit
critique qui va permettre
progressivement de d'être plus à l'aise
par rapport à cet exercice de discerner
ce qui semble être quand même un peu
douteux et qui semble pour le coup plus
avérées les plus fondées djibril
justement ces exercices là sur les
photos ça donnerait quoi
vous avez été perdu parfois vous avez
des choses vous saviez pas si c'était la
bonne légende ou pas la bonne les ondes
il y avait des fois où visible où il y
avait des poils pouvait se confondre
car c'était très trompeur il avait des
images par exemple j'ai plus du magenta
mais comme il y avait des images
correspondent est vachement à ce qui
était raconté sauf que tu as été
raconter des poules de coupe à induire
en erreur
on peut faire c'est intéressant de
savoir qu'on peut faire mentir une image
nos dibril oui c'est intéressant parce
qu'une simple image une légende
et tout si on aurait une image plus
comme ça on pourrait dire oui
cette image représente ceux ci et si on
n'a pas la légende qui va avec
eh ben on n'aurait pas pu avoir ce
qu'elle représente vraiment fait c'est
tout à fait ça et c'est parfois la
différence peut-être interrogé hanau
cloud et là-dessus centre au fond la
formation et puis la villa font pas
grand monde si on détourne une image si
on les fait de dire ce qu'elle ne dit
pas je me souviens des des photos sur
staline ont supprimé des gens se
trouvent les plus gay soit là c'est vrai
que yahia fil ténu entre la formation et
la propagande nom son âge et une image
découpée s'est installée même image mais
découpés et 20 soldats qui portaient
femmes et ensuite on payait plus que la
femme soldats en très petits plans et
ont gonflé la différence entre banques
comment quelqu'un d'autre quelqu'un
comment oublier le temps tout peut
changer très vite avec un simple
découpage bien sûr chloé là dessus sur
tout le réseau
l'image ci dessus et là les gens que
nous faire changer l'image en soi big et
vous êtes procès de m est ce que il faut
la lecture par exemple d'article ou de
deux documents de presse ça peut aider
aussi pour apprendre le français prendra
écrire pour apprendre à mieux lire mêlée
en fait on les deux c'est à dire que la
fréquentation des articles développent
les compétences de lecture certes le
fait de lire des articles même d'écouter
d'écouté des podcasts des
émission de radio de vraiment développer
cette compétence de compréhension ne
serait-ce que de compréhension d'un
discours oral par exemple ça travaille
cette compréhension de la compétence de
compréhension ça travaille aussi à
l'attention qu'on porte aux mots aux
tournures de phrases on travaille
beaucoup là-dessus justement donc va par
exemple avec l'eau et margot a travaillé
sur la manière dont dont des articles
pouvait reprendre des sondages ou des
statistiques et avec les mêmes
statistiques le même sondage faire dire
des choses différentes
sans pour autant mentir mettre dans la
foi dans le choix des chiffres qu'on va
mettre en valeur mais également dans la
formulation la manière de tourner les
phrases la structure de l'article donc
toutes ces considérations là
effectivement permettre de de renforcer
ses compétences de lecture mais je
dirais qu'un versement
la fréquentation des oeuvres des oeuvres
littéraires aussi le travail
d'interprétation d'oeuvres littéraires
le travail sur la langue en sont donc la
grammaire le vocabulaire
ça permet aussi d'affûter son esprit
critique ça permet également de
travailler de de travail et cette
compréhension et est donc inversement
c'est aussi par la fréquentation des
oeuvres littéraires finalement quand on
travaille sur l'esprit critique et qu'on
est con et encore plus attentif aux mots
qu'on rencontre dans les discours au
quotidien à la télévision sur les
réseaux sociaux etc
dire vous avez raison de parler des
sondages parce que les questions ne sont
jamais neutres les questions qu'on pose
c'est évidemment oui parfois les
réponses qu'ils vont être donnés par les
deux professeurs d'histoire donc
l'instant quoi là le lier aux autres
enfin le la différence entre
l'information la propagande
l'utilisation de l'image etc
ça c'est un c'est de creuser l'histoire
en faut un
oui complètement alors après moi je fais
de l'histoire et de la géographie et en
fait les artistes que j'avais donnée
avec la virile sur les photographies
c'était justement biographie sur le
thème de l'environnement et du
changement climatique et sur ce thème là
deux choses qui ont qui ont circulé qui
faisait croire qu'en fait ce changement
climatique n'existait pas donc le
climato-scepticisme aussi d'exercer leur
leur esprit critique face à ces images
il ya comme l'a très bien dit gerry et
je le remercie le rôle des légendes et
drôle de cadrage aussi comme l'asie à
main sont vraiment très importantes
alors en histoire oui on va
effectivement très souvent analysé des
discours politiques de personnalités
politiques par exemple vous avez parlé
de staline quand on sait le programme
d'histoire de terminale on va
effectivement travailler sur des régimes
qui ont largement utilisé la propagande
donc c'est toujours effectivement très
intéressant de pouvoir travailler à la
fois la discipline et en temps c'est
cette commande ça discute en cette
matière transversale quel ennemi donc
l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information et c'est ce que vous
disait lui-même un an au démarrage au
début de cette émission c'est en fait on
fait de l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information quand on fait ça matière à
des moments ponctuels pas forcément
toujours régulier les élèves se rendent
compte qu'on ne fait pas seulement de la
discipline mais aussi qu'on essaie de
les éveiller à aller lire à comprendre
et à produire des médias justement il
fallait aux élèves à la de choses est ce
que comme le disait d'élever guémas
grosse taille au fond cette formation à
l'information peut vous aider pour
d'autres matières ça ouvre l'esprit ça
permet d'aller chercher des choses et
c'est vrai couteau je ne sais pas quand
on vous voit liste ou quand on étudie
l'histoire par exemple on a aussi
peut-être après envie d'aller d'aller
chercher la vérité est ce que ça vous a
est-ce que vous avez ça nous a aidé pour
les autres matières
lorsque c'est des choses très
différentes ou faux toujours une
pochette pour chaque plus long et plus
loin que l'information puisque la
formation juste on est en cours et même
pour la rédaction ça m'a permis de
rédiger d'une manière un peu plus
pertinent de repenser colère pour placer
les informations qui me tenait vraiment
à coeur de partager plutôt que juste
rester dans l'attendu c'est sur cette
question alors oui moi ça m'a servi pour
un chapeau que j'ai un autre concours
par exemple
article en histoire des personnes qui
parlent et où le discours bat déjà la
facilité de compréhension du qu'on a
souvent des habitués à lire des articles
et touba dans la classe médias mais
aussi l'esprit critique passé face aux
discours des personnes n'est alors plus
bas pour rejoindre ce que ce cas du
cloud est par exemple en histoire
géographie en à des exercices comme ça
avec des études et documents et il faut
ces importantes de limiter le sujet les
données c'est pas ce qui manque en fait
toutes ses limites et c est donc ce
alice l'esprit critique on a pu
développer en lisant ces articles ça m'a
beaucoup aidé aujourd'hui l'exercice et
djibril le travail que vous avez fait
sur ces photos sur ces légendes
est ce que vous vous dites vous l'avez
fait pour ça mais est ce que je me dis
tiens ça pourrait me même ça m'ouvre un
peu l'esprit pour d'autres choses pour
d'autres quand je lis des choses quand
je fais quand je travaille d'autres
matières dans le temps plein en france
[Musique]
vous proposer toujours à aller chercher
la bonne information comme des fois
quand je vois la tour pedia où nous
autres cibles mais généralement moi je
regarde qu une seule source
bah ça m'amène à en regarder plusieurs
c'est pour voir si vraiment
l'information est vraiment agréable
c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien chez
les questions alors bon mari ce boost
aie aie aie aie lyonnais de biggie sur
le l'actualité le rapport à l'actualité
quand on enseigne un peu le cette
formation à l'information pour les
élèves
est ce que il faut être dans l'actualité
chaude qui intéresse peut-être tout le
monde ou est ce qu'au contraire il faut
savoir prendre un peu de recul
alors j'ai envie de dire ça dépend ce
qu'on veut faire
la soliste et chaude c'est toujours ce
qui va intéresser et c'est souvent ce
dans quoi on va être plongée de fait
puisqu'on a appris le matin la veille
donc mais par contre si on veut vraiment
prendre le temps une analyse critique
autant le temps de la construction d'un
production médiatique de qualité c'est
celle du temps long aussi et le temps
l'analyse il est long aussi
donc si ce qu'on veut travailler avec
les élèves c'est davantage un travail
qui va prendre du temps a défriché à
croiser des sources et par bateau sur
quelque chose de plus anciens ont en
tout cas quelque chose qu'on a
différentes sources différents
témoignages qui on pourrait travailler
par contre on peut très bien travailler
sur l'actualité plus récente mais
justement il faut apprendre aux élèves à
faire attention parce que le temps de la
vérification le temps de l'investigation
n'a pas encore exister et qui fait aussi
y avoir des erreurs qui sont produites
pas cependant se précipita et donc voilà
les deux sont intéressants dans les
dents dépend de lui qui en cas de
travaux qui sont un peu différents c'est
doux c'est différent dans la manière de
traiter vous êtes devenu un levier je
suppose que vous êtes d'accord avec
cette balise 1 on est tout à fait et
puis bon après dans des cas particuliers
leopard et informe des actualités
chaudes qui sont vraiment difficiles à
traiter en classe avec lesquels on
marche sur des oeufs
donc on peut aussi on concevoir que
selon le contexte selon type d'actualité
d'enseignants ne sommes pas forcément à
l'aise avec cette actualité ça peut
arriver
après c'est vrai que par ailleurs
travaillé sur sur l'actualité chose ça
prend même s'il paraît du monde qui nous
entoure du monde ne surent pas vraiment
du monde présent dans lequel on vit est
bon les margaux je crois qui mentionnait
le rituel de veille de veille
d'actualité quotidien avec leurs classes
participaient à cette situation nouvelle
quotidienne d'actualité dans différents
cours tous les jours des élèves
présentés quelques actus du jour avec
des contraintes de temps parfois
quelques petits contraintes comme par
exemple présenté l'acte us to forme de
dessin en s'appuyant sur des dessins
d'actualité ou ou alors faire jouer les
faire jouer les élèves avec un arabe
avec des d actualité dans lesquels on va
glisser une info qui par exemple mais en
tout cas c'est vrai que avoir ce regard
sur le quotidien sur l'oeil sur le monde
dans lequel on vit c'est c'est quand
même assez précieux mais bon c'est ça va
effectivement je trouve complètement
maryse ça va ça va
dépendre de l'objectif est pour entrer
c'est vrai dans le fond d'un sujet on a
besoin de ce recul sur vous par les
faits d'actualité sont peut-être parfois
difficile d'être traités parce qu'on
sait pas très bien qu'on les pende parce
que parier peut-être parce que la charge
émotionnelle et est très forte je pense
à l'attentât dont a été victime votre
votre collègue samuel pâtit par exemple
c'est compliqué parce qu'il ya un besoin
sans doute d'en parler et ça n'est pas
facile c'est pour ça je disais
l'actualité quand elle est très chaude
elle est toujours difficile à manier
c'est pas facile c'est pas non plus des
études c'est très facile pour pour vous
oui totalement parce qu'il ya
effectivement on connaît la loi la loi
en tout cas le principe mans km en
savait plus où marie à fait proches à
l'émotion est forte c'est aussi la
l'identification il ya plein processus
d'identification va pas rentrer dans le
détail mais là c'est la saison là
c'était particulièrement fait qu'à la
scène avec pour des élèves venaient
effectivement il faut tout quitte ou qui
étaient rassemblés c'est à dire
l'identification saint-aulaye avec des
douleurs de proximité géographie les
valeurs qui sont atteintes des valeurs
de la république sont atteintes
bien sûr hélas rexel c'est difficile de
2,2 ça peut être compliqué ça peut être
très compliqué pour ces raisons là parce
qu'il ya charge émotionnelle forte et
puis aussi le fait que l'enseignant et
face à 30 35 élèves au lycée souvent
voire plus et une actualité chaude peut
aussi entraîner d rect d'érection chaude
et ça il faut être
il faut se sentir capable ou sentira
même de l'accueillir on ne sait jamais à
quel point que la réaction
donc on peut comprendre qu'il puisse y
avoir des à des réticences soin de les
appréhensions
en tout cas c'est que c'est vrai que
c'est c'est toujours c'est toujours pour
certaines actualités sais c'est pas
toujours évident oui sur ce sujet oui je
rejoint lionel effectivement alors cela
sur l'assassinât de sa mère pattie
c'était vraiment un contexte très
particulier parce qu'en plus ça a lieu
juste avant les vacances
donc il ya quinze jours qui se sont
déroulée mais une rentrée un peu
particulière puisque à ce moment là ont
commencé à être dans un nouveau
confinement une deuxième vague donc
c'était assez particulier
mais de manière générale lorsqu'on a une
actualité chaude c'est toujours
extrêmement complexe à traiter parce que
les élèves ont leur sensibilité les
professeurs avec leurs personnalités ont
leur sensibilité
donc on a tout à fait le droit de ne pas
vouloir traiter un sujet trop chaud et
je pense que quand on pense quand même
qu'il faut d'abord demander aux élèves
s'ils ont envie d'en parler alors si le
single leur demander si ce moment en vie
et décidé que l'on n'est pas à ce jour
là à le traiter avec eux et le faire
peut-être plus tard donc vous voyez tout
à l'heure si on voulait travailler sur
le show sur le plus ancien mais là ça
peut être justement décalé dans le temps
pour que tout le monde sera peut-être
plus plus comment dire tranquilles
sereins par rapport aux sujets on peut
essayer de le faire un show parce qu'il
ya un besoin très fort des élèves
mais dans ce cas là il faut aussi
accepter d'entendre des choses qui sont
moins réfléchi peut-être parce que
justement on est à chaud et ça ça peut
être vrai deuxième passion parfois on
accueille des choses très très émouvante
aussi auquel on s'attendait pas et tant
mieux parce qu'ils sont fous du soutien
du support donc c'est des déjections
délicat et je pense que il faut pas
qu'on entrait ces enseignants
d'absolument parler de ces sujets quand
ils ont lieu il faut comprise
chacun à sa façon avec sa sensibilité
avec son expertise son expérience décide
de quête de quelle façon il va le faire
et aussi de manière concertée
c'est souvent les profs d'histoire
parfois les profs de lettres aux siens
mais qui sont chargés de faire les
débats avec les élèves sur les sujets
tendu et on est on est pas forcément
formés à ça et donc ça peut être bien
aussi de discuter entre collègues sur
voilà comment s'organiser ce que m
est-ce qu'on peut pas être à deux passes
à ses élèves parce que c'est plus facile
à deux que d'être seul face à ses
paroles à chaud c'est en plus donc y
travailler sur la formation vous savez
combien parfois l'émotion n'est pas
forcément la meilleure conseillère it up
enfin pour l'information anna clos et
margaux et bwin est ce qu'il ya des
sujets comme ça est ce qui vous est
arrivé de demander à vos enseignants de
dire
voilà il ya tel sujet j'aimerais bien
qu'on en parle oui moi c'est
personnellement c'est à les mesures
prises par rapport à octobre dans
l'établissement pour les terminales et
du débat avec mes profs sur ce sujet
c'est bien c'est une bonne idée
marou ça vous êtes arrivés moins de 2 de
vuvu nouveaux camarades de dire tiens
j'aimerais bien qu'on traite tel ou tel
sujet ça nous intéresse valls est en
fait notre cour de mc ont fait pas le
programme qu'on avait prévu de fermer
ont fait justement chaque mercredi on a
on parle d'un fait d'actualité politique
qui s'est passé et les répercussions que
ça peut avoir dans le pays et cetera
donc on a parlé par exemple du putsch
qui a eu en birmanie ce genre d'oubli
c'est très intéressant parce que je vois
que et ccc d'un très bon courage tout on
voit que ce qui vous intéresse ou
fausser la marche du monde
c'est pas vous n'êtes pas forcé motors
au près sûr par exemple est ce que les
élections présidentielles de 2022 ça
vous intéresse ou parfums dibril dibril
est ce que vous allez suivre ça les
élections présidentielles oui
l'actualité oui c'est là qu'elle est un
moment important de fond de notre pays
d'autres terres publiques
oui je ne sais pas pas plus jours non ce
n'est pas tous les jours non c'est tous
les cinq ans sa vie assez vite pourtant
c'est pas religieuse avait raison margot
par exemple les élections
présidentielles c'est des choses que
vous allez suivre
ben je vais être un peu obligé parce
qu'obligés voilà mais une par passion ou
par obligation plus tôt moi je pense que
c'est quand même important parce que
c'est notre pays quoi donc faut se tenir
informé surtout qu'on est censés voter
bientôt donc
est-ce que vous aurez le
le droit de vote en 2022
pile poil pile poil chloé oui mais je
peux la voir
oui et anna est donc alors ça c'est
important parce que c'est la première
fois que vous allez voter si vous y
allez je vais pas vous demander si vous
allez voter pour qui si vous y offre
après ça c'est votre notre liberté mais
c'est la première fois que vous pourrez
exercer votre votre droit de vote
ces quelques et le jeu justement le fait
d'avoir eu ces formations aux jo ça
est-ce que vous pensez que ça vous
permet peut-être d'être mieux éclairé
que si vous ne les aviez pas suivi je
pense que ça va me permettre de vraiment
prendre du recul par rapport à ce qu'a
dit et notamment dans les interviews par
exemple on peut entendre là je suis
l'actualité politique pour les futures
élections parce qu il ait nous prendre
du recul par rapport à ce qu'annonçaient
les potentiellement futur politicien
déjà politiciens et par rapport souvent
on voit que la différence entre la
question du journaliste est ce qu'ils
disent est d'abord comme réponse est
très différente de ce que répond la
personne est d'ailleurs ça vous
intéresserait
si au bout demandez vous qui est kate
lycée l'aide qui serait peut-être pas en
cours préparatoire ou encore fac l'année
prochaine de deux participe à des
émissions sur les élections
présidentielles de donner votre
sentiment de l'interview de roger
peut-être d'aider des candidats aux
dépens parle de colza est ce que ça vous
intéresserait au magot oui je pense que
c'est important pas qu'on puisse se
renseigner qu'on puisse donner notre
avis aussi c'est toujours à prendre
everell oui quoi
pourquoi pas prêts risqués il faut
sortir un peu légitime aussi un paumé
mais après tout voilà vous êtes vous
êtes déjà fait quand même c'est quand
même vous l'avenir des deux pays donc
c'est important de vous entendre
est-ce que voilà vous avez vous avez
raconté qu'il y avait des choses djibril
vous avez raconté tout à l'heure le
travail que vous avez fait sur les
photos est ce que c'est un travail il me
demande c'est un travail peut-être un
peu différent de celui des autres coûts
est-ce que vous en parler par exemple
chez vous en famille ou est-ce que vous
en parlez avec des camarades
non franchement parfois entre camarades
mais comme tous mes souvenirs on au quai
ana ça permet de ne permettre des
discussions je pense nos deux choses
comme a appris qu'on a envie de partager
on a envie de faire savoir j'ai envie de
l'enseignement que vous prodiguez maryse
et et lionel c'est facultatif c'est sur
options ou c'est obligatoire par mois
g2g 2 2 comment dire conteuse exemple
différentes a donc j'ai oublié de serrer
relève de ma classe de seconde où je
suis à professeur d'histoire géographie
et je suis aussi son prof principal donc
on se voit assez souvent et je jeu mais
en fait un petit peu de cette éducation
à l'information dans tous mes crocs mais
par petites touches
je vais traiter le programme et de temps
en temps je vais faire une petite
incursion voilà un travail d'éducation
des photos pour admettre c'est différent
parce qu'ils étaient passés à fait
partie de l'atelier webradios donc ça
fait maintenant deux ans que ma lancée
ça dans mon lycée et là pour le coup
c'est effectivement quelque chose qui
est complètement ronda là donc je suis
ravie quand j'ai des élèves qui viennent
volontairement une heure tous les mardis
pour travailler sur la voiture donc là
effectivement c'est les élèves
volontaires qui viennent
et cette année on n'a que des signes et
des filles départ de qualité oui est ce
que est ce qu'une mutation générale il
ya plus de filles que de garçons dont ce
genre de deux cours ben là c'est la cas
je sais pas bien dans la tête puis c'est
vraiment moi là bas
en fait il n'y a pas de fin jusqu'à dans
mon établissement n'est pas il n'y a pas
de cours n'est pas de deux clubs
webradios deux clubs médias et donc je
peux difficilement répondre à cette
question blue eco et margaux ont
bénéficié d'un dispositif très
particulier une année particulière où
elles ont pu effectivement de demander à
être une classe qui à cette thématique
là qui est qu'à une casse médias avec
donc à se constituer comme les autres
mais en prenant en considération tout de
même les élèves qui souhaitaient
travailler dans cette perspective là
alors là à savoir si plus de filles sont
intéressés que des garçons par par
l'actualité au tribe inc et son média
jeu là je ne trouve pas de réponse et
puis je serais tout de suite dans la
caricature du sud donc n'y a pas de
réveil se trouvait comme ça dans cette
es ce que de leur génération y avait
aussi beaucoup de garçons qui étaient à
fond dans ce genre de projet on avait
d'ailleurs
alors si effectivement stups est
révélateur c'est qu'on avait un petit
rituel du mardi soir je ne sais pas si
elle s'en souviennent mais le mardi soir
en laissait la porte ouverte à tous les
élèves de troisième qui voulaient venir
faire des projets beaucoup de projets
d'ailleurs soit artistique soit de
publication de deux ouïes de publication
de deux créations et on avait beaucoup
belle mixité garçons filles dans ce
projet là donc je pense qu'on est oui je
pense que les deux seront intéressés par
un garçon et fille sont intéressés par
le sud m'ont pas ce genre de projet et
c'est tant mieux mais donc dans les
classes que vous faites au collège alors
sur l'information là encore c'est
obligatoire ou c'est au site
c'est une option non ce n'est pas une
option
avec avec le qu'en dira la génération de
claude barbeau c'était un peu
particulière mais en fait nous si vous
voulez en est une comment dire mme
équipe de professeurs qui volontaires
pour travailler sur ce projet de classe
médias on a pas d'heure en plus j'adore
en plus dans la semaine pour pour cela
et les élèves en fait ne ne demandent
pas ils ont cette équipe de professeurs
et ils ont ce projet de classe médias et
ce projet de classe médias il ne se
rajoutent pas vraiment se rajoutent pas
vraiment c'est simplement un ongle
pédagogique qu'on adopte dans le travail
qu'on mène en classe avec eux mais c'est
de fectivement d'articuler au maximum
nos disciplines respectives
déjà entre elles et avec cet objectif-là
de vous classer la et de l'éducation
n'est guère question à un peu mais on
arrive presque à la fin de l'émission
mais on voit bien les efforts qui ont
été consentis par l'éducation nationale
vous nous rappeler match boston ça fait
30 ans qu'il ya des classes top ça or on
est dans une société où on a beaucoup
parlé de la poste vérité c'est à dire
que on ne fait plus la différence à la
vérité le mensonge c'est une opinion
elle avait été de viande au pire on l'a
vu avec trump enfin notamment comment
vous expliquer à la fois cette
mobilisation qui est très forte et qui
donne des résultats et en même temps une
société kenner un peu de tout beau
fondre en matière d'information alors
c'est vrai que depuis 30 ans le clemi
existe mais c'est quand même quelque
chose qui est allé croissant cette
éducation aux médias et à l'information
on associe aussi à l'art en france on a
senti que 2015 a été un tournant pas
d'abord parce que ça a été davantage
inscrits dans l'est dans les programmes
parce qu'on l'a connu à cette époque là
aussi les attentes à 2 janvier de
novembre et on a vu le besoin qu'il y
avait de travail et la formation avec
les élèves y lire en dehors de l'école
aussi donc on essaye de mettre vraiment
l'accent sur ce travail là je pense que
c'est assez progressif
je pense que pour les professeurs
malheureusement le et demi donc
l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information
n'est pas forcément inscrits dans leur
formation initiale c'est à dire quand on
devient professeur on est formés à une
discipline en particulier
ça veut donc dire être au tout faire au
tout formés ou bien avoir la chance de
suivre des formations proposées entre
autres par le clemi donc je pense qu'on
est vraiment en train de commandes hier
d'inscrire cette éducation aux médias à
la formation de davantage dans les
programmes et dans les pratiques des
professeurs mais c'est évidemment un
travail qui est en cours qui est pas du
tout achevé on espère qu'il va
progresser et ça explique aussi pourquoi
bon ça ne permet pas forcément de former
tous les élèves à être suffisamment
aguerri à comprendre la formation elle a
partagé liés à la produire
si vous êtes un coup vraiment bien vous
n'êtes pas les seuls responsables de
toute cette fusée de 2,7 post vérité là
qui est quand même assez inquiétante
c'est à dire que la l'impossibilité de
faire le tri entre louvres et il faut
considérer l'un et l'autre comme une
opinion qui se valent après tout schuss
vous tout tout est égal c'est vrai que
c'est c'est vrai que c'est une dérive
assez assez inquiétante et que ce que
vous faites dans vos collègues dans vos
lycées ce que fo d'hybrides ce que fait
on à ce que fit clouer ce que fait ma
roue formidable pour pour lutter contre
ça peut-être pour conclure dibril si je
disais à votre avis quel est le c'est
une question compliquée qu'elle est plus
grand péril des années qui viennent pour
ses excès c'est là qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire sauver la paix dans le monde
lutter contre le terrorisme ou lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
une question idiote au fait que nous
pose mag oh là là peut-être là la santé
donc vous c'est ça qui vous préoccupe
il ferait peut-être donc le
réchauffement climatique est-ce que vous
êtes très mobilisés sur est ce que la
jeunesse et je compte comme comme
représentante de la jeunesse est très
mobilisé sur les impératifs
environnementaux
je pense qu'on est bien mais aussi parce
que on est censé un peut être les
responsables de ce que va être la
planète de demain est responsable c'est
plutôt ce niveau là le sommet mais bon
après on va essayer de gérer ça comme on
peut mieux on essaie de se mobiliser
quoi mais tu aimes bien que le club
quel est le problème vous qui votez vous
une inquiète ou qui vous passionne dans
les années qui viennent
j'évoquais parti kwa siècle en et en
technique en protéger je pense que
c'était problématique en parler ça nous
concerne tous écoutez je vous remercie
infiniment alors je je je vous promets
moi parce que voir les élections
présidentielles fera des émissions avec
vous si vous êtes d'accord
est-ce qu'elle n'a rien à vous avez
envie de devenir journaliste par exemple
ou dans les plans margot c'est la santé
cloué dans le droit international et
jibril
vous savez déjà de bonnes idées moi
j'aimerais bien un jour nous serons
spock tu as génial ça c'est bien parce
qu'ils voyagent
c'est une vie absolument formidable
merci merci infiniment à tous merci maïs
bros time merci du naming
merci maman merci anna merci chloé et
merci marine et puis on se retrouve très
vite pour un nouveau numéro de paf et on
se retrouve aussi très vite j'espère
avec vous au revoir
[Musique]